we works IPO is coming as soon as next
month the investors might rightly be
wondering if it's a bridge to nowhere
this is obviously an unprofitable
company we've seen a number of these
companies come to market this year with
actually mixed results a lot of numbers
are swirling around but if you really
want to understand weworks business
model look at this 147 billion dollars
that's how much the company is on the
hook for in the lease obligations
leading up to its public offering it
says a lot about how the company works
and why some investors are eyeing the
risks you probably know we work which
recently changed its name to the we
company as an office space with a
specific aesthetic you know what we're
talking about the glass walls plants
cafes mid-century style furniture we
works basic business model is to lease
large spaces
transform them to look like this and
then rent them out to individuals and
companies at a higher price our software
finds the best buildings in the best
locations before we even begin
construction we build full 3d models to
make sure we're creating environments
that allow members to thrive as of 2018
the company operated more than 35
million square feet of space globally
and it currently occupies 528 locations
in 29 countries around the world speed
is important because on average we open
two new locations every single day to
cover the cost of the renovations and
leases rework charges individuals and
companies through four different
membership options for one of the
cheaper plans a member can bring their
laptop and sit in a common area if space
is available and for the most expensive
plan companies can rent out full offices
suites or entire floors we work also
offers a service called powered by we
full custom build outs for larger
companies so why are some analysts and
investors skeptical well some are
concerned with those lease obligations
when we work signs a lease on a building
in the US they commit to an average of
15 years but we works members only
commit to an average of 15 months
reworks obligations top forty seven
point two billion dollars but it's
customers have only signed leases on
three point four billion dollars worth
of space recently the company has
started signing more long-term clients
but still with 528 locations that's a
lot of time and space to fill it's
unclear how much space we work needs to
fill to break-even but the company's
occupancy rate fell from 84 percent to
about 80 percent in the final quarter of
2018 the company said the drop was
caused by expansion new offices
traditionally take up to 18 months to
fill but it's unclear what would happen
if suddenly fewer startups and
freelancers were looking for work space
which could happen in an economic
downturn it's also unclear what would
happen if existing tenants started to
default one place investors are looking
for precedent is International workplace
group formerly known as Regis a swiss
company with a similar business model to
we work during the economic downturn in
the early 2000s iwgs us unit filed for
bankruptcy as its revenue fell but
long-term leases remained in place we
work has said it's flexible business
model would help keep it safe in a
downturn the company's rapid expansion
has helped it stay out in front of
competitors but some investors are
concerned that can change that's because
we works business model is easy to
replicate the company has filed for some
industrial design and furniture patent
protections but anyone with enough cash
can lease out industrial office space
and flip it and they have a new
york-based rival no-tell hit an
estimated 1 billion dollar valuation
following a recent round of funding and
in 2017 Blackstone acquired a majority
share of the office Group a flexible
workplace provider in the UK investors
will have to decide if we work size and
flexibility are enough to protect it in
a period of economic uncertainty